seit dieser woche ist es quasi offiziell
die groko ist tot
sie weiß es nur noch nicht spd rückt
nach links cdu rückt nach rechts wie
soll man da noch regieren und will es
geht nicht eigentlich geht's nicht sie
wäre es natürlich trotzdem machen
denn wer lässt bei so miesen umfragen
eine regierung platzen
cdu und spd haben sich letztes
wochenende zur gruppentherapie
zurückgezogen um mal für sich zu klären
wer sind wir und wenn ja wie lange noch
und ich sage das war höchste zeit meine
damen und herren
zuletzt konnte man diese volksparteien
ja praktisch nicht mehr unterscheiden
deswegen sagt die neue cdu chef in a kk
ja völlig zurecht und ich freue mich
insbesondere dass wir dies nicht nur als
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
heute abend hier unter uns tun
ja warum lasse mich da war doch alles
richtig
[Applaus]
und tatsächlich ging es im cdu
stuhlkreis aber etwas völlig anderes um
das große trauma dieser partei den
pathologischen dachschaden der union den
furchtbaren hkk sagt der september 2015
darf sich nie wiederholen halte ich auch
für relativ unwahrscheinlich zumindest
laut meinem kalender diese
cdu-veranstaltung in berlin war ein
einziger kotau vor den sogenannten
besorgten bürgern warum jetzt mal
ernsthaft weil wieso ich verstehe nicht
wieso entschuldigt man sich für eine
ausnahme situation in der man mal eine
menschliche regung gezeigt hat früher
hatte die cdu doch auch mal andere
themen 2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen
jedoch nicht diese cdu und csu
selbsthilfegruppe war letztes wochenende
wirklich komplett monothematisch
unterwegs im grunde wie eine kaputte
schallplatte weil er die nadel hängt wir
wollen den ausreise gewahrsam ausweiten
die sicherungshaft einführen
das würde bedeuten dass der gesamte
abschiebe vorgang sich entspannt das
konsequentere abschiebe mit
zurückweisungen an den grenzen ein
striktes regime das thema
zurückweisungen an der grenze dass wir
sagen alter halt halt halt halt halt
halt halt halt ja die union 2009 10
kommt wie dabei sich an es endlich eine
knallharte and order partei so wie
früher
ja warum nicht zurück zum markenkern
nennt man das zwei ganze tage zwei
ganzen geschlagene tage reden die über
den schlimmen
und zwar jetzt kommt der witz ohne dabei
ein einziges mal angela merkel zu
erwähnen ist wirklich wahr
keiner von denen hat auch nur einmal
merkel gesagt offensichtlich ist die
frau jetzt der lord voldemort der cdu
sie kann alles tragen jetzt mal wenn ich
was ist denn das für eine komische
partei die nicht mehr zu ihrer eigenen
geschichte steht die cdu geprägt von
großen persönlichkeiten konrad adenauer
unvergessener gründervater unserer
republik ludwig erhard erfinder der
sozialen marktwirtschaft doktor helmut
kohl legendäre architekt der deutschen
einheit dann drei wahlsiege mit das war
mehr so eine teamleistung und dann kam
auch schon annegret kramp karrenbauer
die erste frau an der spitze der cdu cdu
eine einzige erfolgsgeschichte und noch
mal sorry wegen der flüchtlinge
[Musik]
rwe hatte
über stalin und oder wenn die leute raus
und fotos retuschiert also die cdu setzt
weiter auf flüchtlings panik und die spd
wiederum will plötzlich und jetzt wird's
vogelwild freunde eine linke partei sein
ja und was die in ihrem stuhlkreis alles
aufgeschrieben haben die genossen
da hätte selbst honecker gesagt geht
doch nach drüben freunde
kindergrundsicherung länger
arbeitslosengeld 1 respekt rente und vor
allem wir können mit fug und recht sagen
wir lassen hat vier hinter uns und wir
wollen hat es vier hinter uns lassen und
es ist eine differenzierte bewertung der
lassen als vier hinter uns gelassen hat
vier hinter uns und drittens wir lassen
hartz4 hinter uns ist angekommen hartz4
ist abgehakt geschichte weg also außer
für hartz-iv-empfänger natürlich klar ja
wie heißen demnächst bürgergeld
empfänger wenn die spd alleine regiert
deshalb
was denn
[Applaus]
vielen dank
hartz4 hartz4 ist bald geschichte
deshalb schon jetzt nicht im heute-show
fanshop die hartz4 gedenkmünze ein
kronkorken mit dem gesicht von gerhard
schröder sammlerobjekt wunderbar
wunderbar aber gar nicht so schlecht
diese spd ideen gar nicht so schlecht 12
euro mindestlohn zum beispiel klingt
erstmal nach einer satten steigerung
aber das ist exakt die summe die man
verdienen müsste um im alter wenigstens
knapp über der grundsicherung zu liegen
ich glaube die sozen sind da auf einem
guten weg das merkt man auch an der
leicht verwirrte reaktion der union
es beeindruckt mich nur in der weise
dass ich mir sorgen mache über den
eigentlichen plan der spd weil ich sehe
da eigentlich ist eigentlich egal ist
eigentlich egal was stecken das stecken
klar fast nichts aus dem spd konzept
wird kommen aber die geste zählt
und weil mich mein eigenes sozen bashing
inzwischen tierisch langweilt sage ich
jetzt einfach mal und zwar im namen der
heute-show liebe spd
herzlichen glückwunsch von uns allen
wirklich ernsthaft im vergleich zur cdu
setzt ihr wenigstens auf die besseren
themen um das gebührend zu feiern sind
jetzt ein chor und zwar bestehen dass
einem kohlekumpel einem fließband locker
und natürlich einer allein erziehenden
mutter
bitte sehr
brüder zur sonne zur freiheit nicht
nervig sei das lied danke schön
[Applaus]
und das kommt
das kommt das kommt nach alldem sozen
bashing in dieser sendung jetzt auch mal
von herzen und zur abrundung überreichte
jetzt einfach noch mal habe ich in
diesen symbolischen rosenstrauß
irgendeinem spd-bundestagsabgeordneten
wen haben wir denn heute da mal gucken
da sitzt ja wie immer karl lauterbach
[Applaus]
da noch
er sitzt hier jede woche ich musste mal
mit unserer security
ich fasse kurz zusammen die spd hat
plötzlich wieder ein linkes profil
dafür droht ihr aber eine ganz andere
gefahr verbitterten ex minister mit zu
viel tagesfreizeit tatsächlich berichten
ja wissen sie mehrere medien sigmar
gabriel arbeitet an seinem comeback
ich leite genau diese frage immer direkt
weiter an sebastian pufpaff der mit
seiner pr agentur dass gabriel comeback
begleitet verpufft wie gesagt mit
[Applaus]
genau
gabriel comeback ich wiederhole meine
beiden fragen hat und vor allem wer
welche den spöttischen unterton in
zusammenhang mit unseren kommenden
kanzler dürfen sich gerne sparen ja
genau für solche fälle habe ich ja meine
comeback agentur gegründet unser slogan
latos and friends wir lassen politisch
tote wieder auferstehen
ja weil sie doch gern denn jeder
wirklich jeder hat eine zweite chance
verdient
sollten sie ja eigentlich am besten
wissen der werke wir erinnern uns da da
vor zwölf jahren bei prosieben eine show
mit einem schimpansen bedeutet
erwarteten aber heute gibt es hier
natürlich den großen satiriker im zdf
und viele denken warum nie der
schimpanse er war doch viel lustiger
unser besser aus entscheidet sagt viel
besser aus denn bitte professor tim
guter mann übrigens grüße mit mit sigmar
gabriel zu tun sie hatte drei mal die
chance kanzlerkandidat zu werden hat
aber jedes mal feige gekniffen und jetzt
comeback ja das war ja der alte gabriel
ja unerträglicher choleriker und boller
kopf die marke ja wirklich nennen die
marke sie war damals so versaut internet
intern nannten wie ihn nur damals stigma
gabriel wird nicht besser klären
[Musik]
abgehakt also klar so war damals nichts
von dem was sie sagen ist richtig frost
kann nicht sagen wo ist die mit 25,7
prozent ja sagen wenn du das wissen
willst erst mal auf ich bin doch nicht
hier animateure trauerhalle was ja
blödsinn ist und trotzdem sagen heute 44
prozent der deutschen
gabriel in einer tragenden politischen
rolle würde der spd helfen was beweist
der wähler vergisst schnell und ist sehr
sehr dumm
gabriel kriegt ein rebranding ich mache
jetzt aus dem sack jetzt mal einen
nachdenklichen saucen gandalf aus goslar
ja ja doch doch hier phoenix besucht ihn
in seinem wohnzimmer
das scheint das zu sein was dann oft
auch dazu führt dass das was sie
bürgerlichen anstand verloren geht
einfach 1 1 etwas geduldiger liebevoller
mensch sicherer umgang ist ausgerechnet
sigmar gabriel fordert einen liebevollen
umgang in der politik einmal seine
engsten mitarbeiter haben vorher
terpentin gesoffen um eine woche frei zu
haben ja liebevoll er dies doch auch
heute noch seine genossen in einer tour
bei twitter sowie letzte woche ja gut
aber das kriegt ja keine sau mit nein
wir bombardieren jetzt das netz mit
unserem comeback spots jetzt hier das
mal rein
das ist kurz aber keiner hat aber geil
wie gut dass sex so sollt sein also
kommt super an der spot vor allen dingen
in der target group der
fleischereifachverkäuferin ab 50
grüße ich hab so drauf ich sage ihnen
mit den richtigen tools mache ich jeden
zum kanzler jeden wirklich jeden ja klar
hier kommt passau frei stegner
super super positive ausstrahlung kein
problem noch besser
thorsten schäfer gümbel geiler typ
geiler tvg aber jetzt kommt ein knaller
scharping rudolf wörtchen lineup
reinhardt und weißt du wenn ich bringe
ich sogar dieses toastbrot ins
kanzleramt verstehen was es hier mit
also mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen taktisch überall
lassen ihre risiken liegen und ihr lasst
jetzt dass selbst ein bestechendes ab
[Musik]